la couleur de ce smartphone est juste
incroyable
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on va parler d'un smartphone
qui nous vient tout droit d'asie vous
déjà parlé de ce smartphone n'est pas
très longtemps c'est humide yj z2 alors
aujourd'hui ce qu'on va faire c'est
qu'on va tester le z2 et dans quelques
jours on va tester la version
professionnelle le z2 pro on verra
lequel il plus intéressant dont celle un
peu plus de puissance mais on verra s'il
ya une différence notable notamment en
termes de prix donc ce qu'on va faire
dans cette vidéo c'est qu'on va tester
le humilie gizeh 2 on va l'ouvrir faire
des tests fonctionnalités rapidité
puissante performances autonomie photos
vidéos par la complète vous connaissez
l'histoire donc au louvre on le teste et
à la fin je vous dirais 6e ou milly
gizeh de écoule oui ou non
en attendant s'il vous intéresse vous ai
mis un lien en bas dans la description
un peu un petit message de remerciement
de la part de minutes j'ai écouté merci
à où on a une coque directement dessus
alors ça je crois que c'est la première
fois que je vois des fois y'a des comme
dans la boîte là vous ouvrez vous avez
directement la coque dessus mais vous
allez voir clou du spectacle je le
devine déjà là c'est à mon avis la
version que je préfère voilà flash led
double caméra on reviendra après sur les
fonctions techniques capteur
d'empreintes digitales
ici sur la tranche les boutons de volume
le bouton pour l'allumer double carte
sim qui situe ici le clou du spectacle
c'est la couleur de ce modèle je le
trouve juste magnifique c'est vraiment
la tendance internationale ses couleurs
là c'est dommage de mettre cette coque
vous voulez de protéger c'est quand même
bien mais c'est vrai comme ça il est
juste incroyable
on devine ici quittons coche on y
reviendra un peu plus tard double
appareil photo à l'avant recharge en usb
type ses troupes à s'alléger franchement
termes de prise en main il prend
drôlement bien il est très léger et
surtout je dis une fois de plus ce dos
juste incroyable à l'intérieur de la
boîte
moyon lorsqu'on a link to the world le
packaging est vraiment super bien fait
de la part de midi j une petite lettre
c'est super bien fait bon votre petite
pique pour ouvrir votre gloire de cap
cime
j'aime bien appeler ça comme ça elle
adopte ici du z 2 toujours bien de
pouvoir acheter un petit coup d'oeil on
a ensuite à l'intérieur au très classe
sa sainteté pensée owen plus ce cap le
guen +6 ce câble ou rouge
très sympa bien évidemment c'est de
l'usb tic c'est la recharge
ici vous avez de la recharge rapide là
dessus en 1h20 vous avez recharger tout
votre smartphone est ici un adaptateur
prise jack usb type c on est sur un
smartphone qui coûte quand même moins
300 euros voire en vraiment moins de 300
euros
là je me dis vraiment bravo midi j le
design de ce smartphone la couleur de ce
smartphone est juste incroyable on est
un peu dans la ligne droite de ce que
nous a proposé au nord avec l'honneur
dix s'est dégradé de couleurs sont juste
magnifique
en cette année 2010 hui je pense que
c'est vraiment ce qui a plus réussie en
terme de look
au niveau des dos des smartphones c'est
juste incroyable capteur d'empreintes
digitales qui fonctionne très bien l'ol
c'est un androïde 8 points en or et au
bond et fonctionnent certains auraient
au rien de bien neuf là dedans l'écran
je trouve assez lumineux ici est la
lumière dans le studio
mais ça va o'keefe l affaire bien
lumineux alors une fois de plus on est
sur un smartphone qui coûte pas
forcément très cher vous allez le
trouver à 243 euros shige rebaisse en
termes de rapport qualité prix il est
plutôt pas mal
vous avez un écran de 6,2 pouces une
définition de 2240 par 1080 pixels et je
dois reconnaître que franchement il fait
assez bien le job
par contre un truc à savoir si je trouve
qu'il ya un seul haut-parleur il est
situé juste ici pour des questions
esthétiques ils vous ont fait une
symétrie au niveau des trous il ya
uniquement ce pas alors là qui
fonctionne sans haut parleur mono ce que
je pourrais lui reprocher c'est de leur
passé quelque chose c'est que trouve que
le son est très médium
et maintenant on va regarder avec ce
petit accessoire qui est l adaptateur
usb tisser usb t-il ses ports jack est
arrivé c'est bien qu'il y soit à
l'intérieur
là où certains autres l'enlève néanmoins
je reste quand même assez dubitatif
là-dessus tout simplement parce que
lorsque vous avez tout accroché vous
avez un truc un peu lourd qui pendouille
donc pour le voyage lorsque vous vous
déplacez c'est pas extraordinaire et ça
c'est un peu dommage
malgré tout c'est quand même bien qu'il
soit à l'intérieur mais pas enlever ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quand on branche avec le casque il n'a
plus rien à voir le spectre audio est
vraiment bien on a un grave qui est
vraiment sympa un aigu qui est pas
criarde du médium qui arrache pas les
oreilles c'est assez linéaire je pense
que ça marche plutôt bien alors aussi
j'ai un studio monitor 105 1 062 chez
celui qui marche très très très bien
mais malgré tout je trouve que le son de
l'appareil est vraiment correct ya du
volume sonore ne poussez pas trop à fond
j'ai dit une fois de plus tout pas vous
rendre flous c'est pas le but mais
malgré tout de ce point de vue là c'est
plutôt cool
du point de vue de l'appareil photo vous
avez à l'arrière ici un double module
photo 16 mégapixels plus 8 mégapixels
vous avez exactement la même chose à
l'avant 16 +8 vous servira surtout pour
le mode portrait pour avoir le fameux
effet bloqué alors l'appareil photo
northe pas mal ça n'est pas non plus
chercher des choses complètement dingue
vous avez du hdr le flash ou de faire
des photos en retardateur la taille de
l'image que vous pouvez voir en 4672
part à 3504 vous pouvez choisir un
format 4/3 16/9 mis pas mal de petites
possibilités dessus un mode panoramique
et le fameux mode effet évoqué par là le
fameux flou d'arrière plan
ici aussi vous avez quelques réglages
les eas automatique lentilles sentiment
propriété de l'image vous pouvez régler
la luminosité moyenne faible luminosité
contraste 1 de saturation des t bonds
plutôt pas mal très basique mais ça
fonctionne pour naviguer c'est pas hyper
hyper pratique on pourrait faire baisser
mais c'est pas le cas il faut cliquer à
côté bon ça va si on va prendre ça
fonctionne aussi lorsque vous arrivez
sur le mode vidéo alors vous avez la
possibilité d'avoir des filtres vous
avez quelques petits paramètres vous
avez des modes scène
vous pouvez choisir nuit coucher de
soleil fait portraits paysages portraits
l'option théâtre lumière de bougies pour
avoir quelques petits réglages
intelligent une balance des blancs
pouvaient régler et en vidéo pour filmer
uniquement en full hd 1920 par 1080 ici
pas de quatre cailloux hd de notre côté
est ce que vous n'auriez réellement
besoin en ces sentiments propriété
l'image également ici pour les
paramètres de votre vidéo et vous pouvez
régler le format en troisième pays ou
alors en mp4
alors il n'a pas être un photophone
complètement housni en terme de vidéo ça
fait quelque chose de complètement
dingue
- il fera le job on va pas trop trop lui
en demander je vous donne tant de
stabilisation s'est pas particulièrement
ça m'est rendu lorsque vous avez de la
lumière comme l'a tout de suite est
plutôt pas mal
néanmoins ce qu'on va les faire on va le
faire des tests à l'extérieur en termes
de photos vidéos on va regarder aussi en
faible luminosité
j'ai pas trouvé d'information du tout
sur l'ouverture je pense que midi j veux
pas communiquer dessus
donc on va les voir directement que
samedi une petite vidéo sur la caméra
arrière avec du soleil soleil du fâ
septembre je pense que lorsqu'il ya des
conditions de bonne luminosité
il va fonctionner le capteur aime le
soleil il faut le nourrir assez calmes
en cabine ça fonctionne très très bien
par contre lorsqu'on est en faible
luminosité
à mon avis c'est moi ça ici j'ai
beaucoup moins de lumière forcément ça
serait bien mais on fait quand même le
job alors espaçant les caméras de celle
fille un peu à contre jour ça va j'aime
bien les petits reflet en haut ça marche
pas trop mal
du point de vue logiciel s'en sortent
pas trop trop mal alors après une fois
de plus je me répète beaucoup mais une
fois de plus on est sur un smartphone
qui coûte pas forcément trop trop cher
pas trop lui en demander
j'aime bien ce côté là c'était un peu il
fait peut-être divin accusés mais qui a
réussi c'est très très drôle
comme quoi d'armes de photos/vidéos s'en
sort pas trop mal il fonctionnera bien
en conditions de bonne luminosité tout
de suite en faible luminosité on perd
pas mal de détails c'est pas non plus un
capteur complètement dingue mais malgré
tout je trouve qu'ils s'en sort quand
même pas mal
là vous voyez typiquement sur la plante
si je vais chercher un peu dedans j'ai
pas mal de détails et ça c'est plutôt
bien pour résumer pour moi la photo
vidéo fonctionnera bien dès lors que
vous avez beaucoup de lumière pour un
duo tout cas de la lumière extérieure
s'en sortira plutôt pas mal
si tout de suite vous allez le privé de
lumière c'est là où il va s'offrir un
petit peu attention à ce que voulait
filmer et que ça bouge
y'a pas de stabilisateur ça peut tout de
suite être un point un peu négatif en
termes de performances on a un
médiathèque 6763 opta core cadencé
jusqu'à 2
higuain est à la carte graphique c'est
une manie j'ai 71 étaient deux vous avez
si giga de ram 64 giga de stockage bon
c'est pas une bête de course en terme de
chargement voyez il m'a un petit peu de
temps sur pib g après c'est aussi un jeu
un peu gourmand forcément très content
on a chanté une chanson anti foot et non
plus en sa faveur
live ou reconnu en qualité graphique
moyenne c'est tout à fait normal on va
maintenant essayer et voir si ça le fait
souper léger
voilà ça c'est fait pour jouer pbg qu'il
ya quelques petits moments où ça lag un
peu mais dans l'absolu expérience est
quand même pas mal
on va éviter de se faire shooter parce
que les mecs sont hypertendus ce matin
on va faire un petit test de puissance
performances sont en tout
il obtient la note de 82 1895 s'ils vont
regarder directement sur en tout ou pour
trouver un taux de 80 de 1825 il faut
descendre il faut descendre et on la
trouve pas en termes de performances on
aura compris ça sera pas le modèle le
plus rapide si on veut de la performance
pure et dure il faudra aller sur le z2
pro qu'on va tester d'ici quelques jours
qu'il ya un elio p60 un soc de
médiathèque qui lui par contre devrait
aller beaucoup plus vite et bien moi je
vais pas faire un mauvais procès à ce
qu'on me disait de luigi midi midi j ou
milly j'y pense je veux pas faire un
mauvais procès à ce qu'on me disait
d'eux je trouve pas mal on est sur un
smartphone entrée qui flirte avec le
moyen de gamme je dirais qu un produit
d'entrée de gamme plus plus plus
le design est irréprochable le dos est
juste magnifique
les caméras sont pas mal la performance
suffira pour aller relever vos emails
sur les réseaux sociaux faire quelques
jeux pas trop gourmands instagram snap
chat facebook tout ce que vous voulez ça
fonctionnera parfaitement bien vous
nouerez absolument aucun problème si
vous cherchez plus de puissance je suis
pas sûr ce sens moral qu'il faille aller
mais pour avoir un produit pas cher
très joli mais qui fonctionne bien il
sera parfaitement la faire tout au plus
que l'autonomie est pas trop mal
boutonnée une journée avec une batterie
de 3850 millions terreur alors une
journée ça dépend une fois de plus de
votre utilisation est toujours un peu
compliqué - testant une journée il fait
la faire il fait la faire sur des emails
quelques jeux quelques coups de fil
quelques messages j'utilise pas à fond
toutes les journées j'utilise de temps
en temps quand j'en ai besoin
si vous avez utilisation intensive il va
tenir peut-être moins qu'une journée ça
va vraiment dépendre de vous volent un
peu pour ce test aujourd'hui du midi j
z2 dites moi ce que vous en pensez
est-ce que vous avez déjà eu des
produits du midi j'y suis c'est le cas
ben dites moi ce que vous pensez de la
martre retour d'expérience est ce que
vous avez été satisfait oui ou non
comment vous trouvez celui là moi je
trouve que le dow est juste incroyable
c'est vraiment une très très belle
réussite de la part du midi j julie
d'ici quelques jours
on va tester le modèle z2 trop d'eau en
céramique recharge par induction celui à
l'ap à la recharge par induction
contestera d'ici quelques jours je vous
invite donc à vous abonner à rester
connectés à
arqués toutes vos questions suggestions
directement d'un commentaire soyez sages
et à très bientôt
[Musique]
oh